did you guys know that Chris Paul almost  joined the Los Angeles Lakers back in  2011 the Lakers hornets and Rockets all  had a three-team trade that would have  sent Chris Paul to the Los Angeles  Lakers and Paul Gasol to the Houston  Rockets but the NBA at the time who were  also the acting owners of the Hornets  decided to veto that trade now nobody  knows for sure why exactly the NBA  decided to not let this trade go through  there's a bunch of rumors and there's a  bunch of speculations to different  reasons but there is no definite reason  why David Stern decide to ax that trade  but Chris Paul was traded to La just not  the Lakers it was the Clippers where  they did form Lob City with him DeAndre  Jordan and Blake Griffin but you know I  think that Chris Paul and Kobe Bryant  that have been one of the best back  courts in the NBA Pride that we've ever  seen But I want to know what you guys  think why did you guys think that the  NBA did not let Chris Paul join the  Lakers